Übung 8
herabsteigen starten sie seitlich auf
einer Treppenstufe oder einem Stepper
stehend und halten sich gegebenenfalls
an einem Treppengeländer fest oder
stützen sie die Hände seitlich am Rumpf
ab halten Sie Ihren Oberkörper aufrecht
und lassen sie ein Bein seitlich der
Stufe Absinken bis die Ferse den Boden
berührt indem sie das andere Bein im
Hüft und Kniegelenk beugen achten Sie
darauf dass ihr ugtes Bein auf der Stufe
in der Beinachse bleibt wenn die Ferse
den Boden berührt drücken sie sich
wieder nach oben in die
Ausgangsstellung wiederholen Sie diese
Übung 10 bis 15 Mal auf einer Seite und
wechseln Sie dann das
Bein